la parole est un monsieur pierre charon
pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le garde des sceaux ministre de
la justice madame qu'il s'agisse de la
remise en liberté en raison de
conditions de détention jugée insalubre
à bois d'arcy de la libération de trois
délinquants d'eure-et-loir faute de
place en prison du régime de semi
liberté dont bénéficie le présumé auteur
récidiviste de viol sous la menace d'une
arme à colombes cet été ou de l' attaque
de train en toute impunité
ce sont autant d'exemples récents qui
témoigne de la cacophonie du système
pénal de l'incurie par faute de moyens
des services de contrôle et de l'ineptie
et de l'inefficience des mesures
d'aménagement de peine pour des cas
d'une telle gravité
nous sommes je pense unanimement
d'accord sur ces bancs pour déplorer le
manque cruel de place dans nos
établissements pénitentiaires puisque
1er septembre
on comptait elle 60 7088 détenus pour 50
7938 places opérationnelles
ce sont des conditions de détention
inadmissibles nous divergeons en
revanche sur la manière de traiter la
question tant nos visions de la société
s'opposent laxisme angélisme dogmatisme
président à toutes vos décisions prises
sous la haute surveillance du syndicat
de la magistrature
vous êtes garde des sceaux par la
gardienne du mur des cons ce sont cent
mille places qu'il faut atteindre pour
avoir une politique pénale qui
fonctionne à peu près avec une exécution
des peines sans délai il était
responsable de savoir que cent mille
peines de prison ferme sont actuellement
en attente d'exécution et d'interrompre
le programme immobilier de construction
mais vous préférez traité l'engorgement
des prisons par la suppression de peines
plancher ou innover avec votre projet de
contraintes pénale qui n'est autre
qu'une variation du sursis de mise à
l'épreuve de la comme toujours de la com
rien que de la com vous préférez bannir
la peine elle-même du vocabulaire pénale
installant par là même dans notre pays
une situation d'impunité signal
désastreux pour les délinquants et
méprisant pour nos forces de police
c'est une manière dangereuse mais très
sûr de nourrir les extrêmes
quelle suite comptez vous donner aux
travaux conduits par l'administration
pénitentiaire
en 2009 et 2010 qui fixe et en tenant
compte des aménagements de peine
un chiffre optimum du nombre de places
de prison nécessaire c'était pourtant un
exercice de prospective sont
intéressants mais déjà dépassé
malheureusement dont il serait utile de
s'inspirer pour ne pas voir la situation
devenir ingérable pourquoi ne pas
poursuivre un vrai programme de
construction de places de prison
les syndicats des personnels
pénitentiaires le souhaitent les forces
de l'ordre même les avocats et les
détenus le souhaitent pour des raisons
de dignité humaine je vous parle pas du
conseil de l'europe
déjà pointée en ce rapport de mai
dernier la surpopulation de nos prisons
la surpopulation carcérale ne démontre
pas qu'il ya trop de condamner mais
qu'il n'y a pas assez prison madame le
garde des sceaux
ma question se résume en une phrase
pensez vous pouvoir avoir longtemps
raison contre la société française
madame 1
christiane taubira garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice pour vous
répondre
oui monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur pierre charon
manifestement il peut vous rafraîchir la
mémoire sur les politiques conduites par
ces gouvernements que vous ne vous êtes
pas contenté d'ailleurs de soutenir mais
que vous avez accompagné au jour le jour
je vais donc vous rafraîchir la mémoire
et vous dire que ce gouvernement a le
courage moral et politique d'attaquer
les vrais problèmes d'affronter les
réalités et de tirer constat des
résultats désastreux produit par ces
politiques pénales que je dis bien au
pluriel
tant qu'elles furent disparates et
divergentes conduite par l'ancien
gouvernement et les politiques carcéral
nous tenons compte de ce fait ces
politiques pénales monsieur le sénateur
elle été marquée notamment par un droit
de la peine et de l'exécution de la
peine absolument qu'on fuit et
inefficace marquée par des injonctions
contradictoires d'incarcérer de plus en
plus et en même temps d'aménager de plus
en plus une capacité illogique de
désarticuler la société pour laquelle
vous avez fait des miracles
la capacité illogique c'est cette
politique pénale était marquée aussi par
une gestion calamiteuse des flux
carcéraux parce que vous avez introduit
dans le code de procédure pénale des
mecha
nice mme comme la série place
surveillants de la surveillance de faire
de peine qui n'a jamais fonctionné et
parcours a été marqué vos résultats
désastreux par un taux de condamnation
récidive légale légal qui a presque
triplé en dix ans sur le sénateur par un
taux exorbitant et dangereux de sorties
sèches de nos établissements
pénitentiaires donc toute l'europe en
amérique du nord
on sait que les sorties sèches sont des
facteurs d'aggravation de la récidive
alors oui nous avons le courage moral et
politique d'affronter cette réalité de
mettre un terme aux facteurs
d'aggravation la récidive de préserver
la sécurité des français
oui nous le faisons et nous le faisons à
partir nous le faisons à partir de
travaux de recherche de rapports
parlementaires dont certaines ont été
consignés par des personnes de votre
sensibilité
nous le faisons à partir d'une
conférence de consensus dont certains de
votre perte de votre sensibilité à
laquelle ils ont participé
nous le faisons après une large
concertation nous avons le courage nous
d'affronter la lutte contre la récidive
nous allons construire des palaces de
prison nous avons construit commencer à
reconstruire mais nous avons des
financements parce que vous vous
affichez départ de prison avec zéro euro
de financement le temps de ma la
démagogie est terminé le temps du
courage politique du courage moral et
delà de l'efficacité est advenu ne vous
en déplaise